[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka han yolo and this video we're
breaking down the best fan theories
on who the character at the end of the
latest mandalorian episode is
this covers clone troopers captain rex
and the most obvious of them
which is of course boba fett we're going
to be going over it all
and debunking some of the major theories
that you may have seen in order to
discuss
who we think it will be before the
episode airs next week
obviously full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
episode yet then i highly recommend that
you check
out now make sure you subscribe to the
channel as we're going to be covering
this show every week
and you definitely don't want to miss it
anyway without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so episode one follows the
mandalorian as he returns to tatooine in
order to track down more of his kind
this is so he can chart a course through
the network of covets
and return baby yoda to the jedi in the
episode he comes across kobanth
who just so happens to have boba fett's
armor
and after the two team up to take down a
crate dragon he takes it back
and heads to his ship now throughout the
episode we probably got one of the
biggest prick teasers towards fett
and to actually see what could be him at
the end was a huge moment
that made me drop my jaw faster than
luke dropped his lightsaber and empire
is that a good joke no probably not now
the first theory we need to tackle
comes from michael derosa who says how
do we now it's bob a fit
and not just some random clown might be
australian i don't know but
i like doing that impression now
following this up alex goalie also
said regarding the theory that the
person seen at the end is actually a
clown trooper
if you notice the scar on his face if it
is a clown it would have to be commander
wolf
one of the three troopers that didn't
enact order 66
either that or bobber got that scar in
his battle with a sarlacc
presuming there was one you've never
seen boba fett mate without his helmet
off as an adult so
keep your opinion to yourself anyway
thanks thanks for coming in now
it is a pretty good theory as we do know
that all of the clones were duplicates
of jango fett
who was used as a template to create
them thus
this character could well be a random
clone trooper
or commander wolf we also know that
captain rex was rumored to be in the
upcoming series too
so there are a lot of options now whilst
there was a big buzz about rex
all the way back in march when when
tamira morrison's casting was first
announced
i don't think it was ever actually
confirmed and it was more speculation
over who morrison was playing
rather than actual concrete proof that
he was rex or a clone trooper
zeke the super freak you you know the
lady he's my sweet uncle
45 and drinks special brew and chats up
the birds on a thursday anyway
he says that it could also be rex with
ahsoka
there have been a lot of rumors that
ahsoka will be popping up in the series
at some point
and we do know from clone wars that she
and rex were a pretty tight-knit team
rex
actually appeared in return of the jedi
according to the canon
and he was seen as a bearded trooper who
helped the rebels storm endor
with this show being set five years
after that film
i think he must have really had his life
fall apart in order to be wandering
around tatooine
looking like he's just crawled out of
the sarlacc are you having that now as
zigg says
this would be a good way to introduce
ahsoka
however i think the locations and teaser
back in season one
makes me think that it won't be them i
can actually see ahsoka popping up later
in the season
as amanda reconnects with the jedi and
they just have her dotted about on
tatooine
i'm not sure if it's what i want from
the character now as for the rest of the
clones as we learned in episode 2
their aging process was actually
accelerated so that the army would be
ready in time for the order that put
them into production
there's no real reason to believe that
this stopped
and in the film we learned that the only
clone who didn't possess his accelerated
ageing
was boba fett whom django had requested
in order to raise him as his son
thus i think we can pretty much rule out
the clones and the troopers themselves
as most of them died out not long after
the events of the prequel trilogy
due to their aging process and also
because
i i don't know i don't think that george
lucas thought about it for the original
movies
so had to come up with some way to
explain why they were in there anyway
the point is i did go back and forth
over these series myself because
it seemed like this reveal could be a
bit of a misdirect
and though we instantly thought it was
fat that the show could have been
tricking us
however after watching the episode three
times i think the entire setup of it is
pretty much to point out to us that this
is indeed fed
and the entry itself follows a lot of
things that were set up in the extended
universe
now whilst this cannon was wiped out
when disney bought lucasfilm
they have kept several things in play
including cop vant
who was part of the aftermath storyline
in the original work
cobb pretty much went through the ark
that we see in the show and after he
escaped slavery he found the village of
freetown
that had been ransacked by red key
raiders he wandered into the desert
and crossed paths with one called adwin
charu and his soundcrawler
which does divert slightly from what we
see in the show now the pair found the
mandalorian battle armor on it
and vanden chiru had a fight for it
which led to the former being victorious
banthe went to freetown killed the
raiders and became the sheriff
later he discovered that it was boba
fett's armor and depending on what you
read
fett took it back however in the series
the mandalorian pretty much
changes the path of this and as he takes
the armor
it looks like he's going to be the one
who faces down against fett
now the similarities do pretty much
confirm that this is indeed boba fett
and i would absolutely love it if we got
an episode next week i told his
backstory in more detail
hell give the guy an entire episode over
what happened between return of the jedi
and this
and i'm down now there are also other
clues that confirm this too clearly
boba is looking out for mando and it is
possible that he has been tracking him
because he knows that he's a mandalorian
this explains why he went to fenix shand
in the first season
and can also be seen watching over him
in the episode itself fed of course has
a reason for being on tatooine as that's
where we last saw him
and in the expanded universe after
escaping the sarlacc he was found by
jawas who took his armor
this sets up how cobb got it and as he
didn't have his ship or equipment
fett had to remain on the planet which
further hammers home that this is who he
really is
now on top of this thematically boba
fett deserves redemption
he pretty much missed a magood his way
through the trilogy and though i really
like him
watching those original movies i didn't
really get the sense that he was the
best bounty hunter in the galaxy
purely because he was taken out by a
blind man the sequel trilogy 2 did this
with captain phasma
and for so long fett's reputation was
carried purely by the comic books
and other material that made him seem
much better
him regaining his armor is also him
taking back the mantle
and i really think that it's the best
way to do it if this is boba fett
then his story also parallels obi-wan
who
two hid out in the desert after the
jedi's fall from grace
there were also similarities with mando
escaping the crate dragon
and how boba escaped the sarlacc now
whilst
this definitely could be other
characters i think everything lines up
for it to be boba fett
this this was kind of a waste of your
time this entire video as
you probably already knew that didn't
you but you know what i stretched it to
eight minutes and got the ad revenue so
cheers again what what do you mean
you're unsubscribing no but they could
reveal it as someone else
uh and i've just seen so many theories
that i thought i'd go over them
so we get a pretty definitive answer on
exactly what's going on
anyway that's pretty much debunking
everything and hopefully this video ages
as well as yoda
but if it hasn't and you're watching
this after seeing episode 2
then then let me know what an idiot i am
if you enjoyed the video then please
drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of episode 1 which is going to
be linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away 3
copies of the marvel phase 2 box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below the winner is going to be chosen
at random on the 30th of november
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat is
on the discord server linked in the
description
or you spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you